y brown jackson de 51 años fue nominada
por el presidente estadounidense joe
biden para el cargo el pasado 25 de
febrero el mandatario demócrata elogió
la dedicación inquebrantable al estado
de derecho de la jueza busque una
candidata para la corte suprema con
credenciales excepcionales carácter
intachable y una dedicación
inquebrantable al estado de derecho
conozca a mi candidata la jueza que
tangi brawn jackson hija de un abogado y
una maestra de escuela pública justo sus
estudios de abogacía en la universidad
de harvard su carrera inició siendo
secretaria del juez liberal stephen
breyer y es a su mentor a quien ahora
podría sustituir en el alto tribunal
durante años trabajó como abogada de
oficio para acusados de delitos que no
podían permitirse una defensa 2012 el ex
presidente demócrata barack obama la
nominó para el puesto de jueza federal
del distrito de washington y fue
confirmada a un año después en los
cuatro días de audiencias de
confirmación en el senado varios
republicanos la acusaron de ser
indulgente en la condena de delincuentes
de pornografía infantil que se defendió
así
knightley que es pons de él y he sido
jueza durante casi una década y me tomo
muy en serio esa responsabilidad y mi
deber de ser independiente decido en los
casos desde una postura neutral evalúo
los hechos e interpretó y aplicó la ley
a los hechos del caso que tengo ante mí
sin miedo ni favoritismos en consonancia
con mi juramento judicial
el ex de los 115 jueces nombrados en los
233 años de historia del tribunal
supremo 108 han sido hombres blancos